over the past month or so the angle has
been telling you that there's virtually
no distance between the mobs in portland
and seattle
trying to burn down federal buildings
and the democrats on capitol hill
and once again they've proved our point
for several hours today we saw the
mobsters at work
but they weren't outside the building
they were inside
verbally viciously attacking one of the
most well-respected legal minds in
america
our attorney general bill barr
shame on you mr barr can i just say that
shame on you you have consistently
undermined democracy undermine the
constitution
and undermine the health safety and
well-being of the american people when
you all came here
and brought your top staff you brought
no black people
that sir is systematic racism your
failure to respect the role of peaceful
protest in this country is a disgrace
it's un-american mr barr i just asked
yes or no so let me just tell you a
quote i'm starting to lose my temper
my time and i control it i introduced
hres 1032 which would require this
committee to investigate your conduct as
attorney general and determine whether
you should be impeached
for the record barr's character
his reputation his credentials
are unimpeachable i can't say the same
for those folks
now i certainly couldn't say the same
for any of the democrat loudmouths
hearing hurling insults adam
now lest you forget what's been
happening in major american cities
here's a reminder
[Applause]
get off the property
[Music]
the democrats on the judiciary committee
today however need you to see
something very different and the
protesters
aren't mobs they are mothers and
veterans
and mayors we've seen mothers and we've
seen veterans who are peacefully
protesting
not threatening the federal courthouse
beaten in gas the vast majority of
protesters are peaceful most of the
protests
have been peaceful mr barr you know that
now we have right now in this country
what appears to be
a very organized effort by thousands of
people across the country
to create chaos and undermine our faith
in the rule of law
and the democrats you watch them today
they just
do not care now they're either willfully
and purposefully ignoring the dangers to
our entire system
or they're willing to let it all burn
just to beat donald trump now barr who's
seen a lot in his career
could hardly believe what was unfolding
a member of this committee regardless of
your political views
should condemn violence against federal
officers
i see some of these latin american
countries in central america where
the police are very very brave because
the gangs they're trying to deal with go
to their houses and kill their families
you never think that could happen here
but
you could never think some of the stuff
we're seeing today could ever happen
here
but it is happening here and it's
happening because democrat mayors
governors senators and those congressmen
have made a concerted decision to side
with the very radicals
who are threatening the lives of
innocent americans they're doing it on
interstate freeways
on bridges in federal buildings and
frankly
anywhere where rioters gather
since when is it okay to try to
burn down a federal court if someone
went down the street to the pritiman
court here that beautiful courthouse we
have right at the bottom of the hill
and started breaking windows and firing
industrial grade fireworks in to start a
fire
throw kerosene balloons in and and start
fires in the court
is that okay is that okay now
no the u.s marshals have a duty to stop
that and defend
the courthouse and that's what we are
doing in portland
now make no mistake this is no longer
the democrat party of bill clinton
it's not even the party of barack obama
this
is the party of alexandria ocasio-cortez
elon omar ayana presley the squad
this is the party of antifa this is the
party of radical anarchists and
revolutionaries
who commit any crime against any person
or any piece of property in order to get
their way
and what's stunning to watch is that
these domestic terrorists have become
in their own way an active feature of
the biden campaign
got to keep up the chaos try to provoke
a reaction from federal law enforcement
all to affect the outcome of a
presidential election
and judiciary committee democrats are
taking
cues from these despicable people
performing for a television audience
attempting to carry out what was the
equivalent of
reputational assassination of bill barr
have you now called for law enforcement
to stop using these chemical irritants
on protesters yes or no pepper spray
yes no no i think it's a very important
uh non-lethal
option for protesters
no foreigners yes
sir america was founded on the
principles of free speech
when people resist law enforcement
they're not peaceful blaming my time
i'm surprised at your lack of respect
for a member of congress
i laughed out loud in my kitchen when i
saw that today
the gentlelady was treated with more
deference in that exchange
than she deserved she took her five
minutes to launch a personal attack
on a man with an impeccable record
like her colleague she disassembled
distorted and demonized for purely
political ends
and her little charade for the cameras
isn't just an example of conduct
that is boorish and rude but it's an
insult to the integrity
and history of the entire house of
representatives
what am i supposed to say to my
constituents
when they ask me if the government has
done everything in its power to protect
their loved ones from dying i would tell
them that managing this kind of thing
requires a lot of
uh difficult choices and weighing
different uh
consequences i'm not gonna lie and that
is i am not going to lie to my concerns
i am going to tell them
and the attorney general working
together
they're letting americans die needlessly
because of political reasons is it
permissible for a member of this
committee to accuse the sitting attorney
general of the united states of murder
because that's what we just heard
the membership all the time mr chairman
to say whatever they want
what about rules of decorum rules of
decorum
those were unfortunately out the window
a long time ago
and after all their preening and
strutting and overcharged emoting the
democrats sought to deprive
barr his one brief moment of humanity
i have two children who are cancer
survivors so i feel very
strongly about this issue as a matter of
policy and i believe that the
president's made
clear uh that he will ensure
that they will answer my question will
you stop playing politics with
americans health care in the middle of a
pandemic
everyone should understand where we are
as mob violence consumes the country
we're in the middle of this covid crisis
democrats on capitol hill prefer to
berate
the chief law enforcement official in
the country and float
far left conspiracy theories rather than
working with him
to restore order and maybe just give
people a little hope
and why are democrats doing this why was
there not a single
reason question from even one of them
today
because they know that aoc in the squad
will destroy them
if they deviate from the far left
playbook for just a millisecond
the democrats are more terrified of
alexandria ocasio-cortez
plus three uh because they're worried
about
endor her endorsing a primary challenger
they're worried more about that than
what any reasonable american thinks
ever since the impeachment effort failed
the democrats have jumped on one
crazy theory after another barr is a
thoughtful
and dedicated civil servant he came out
of retirement not because he wanted
something on his resume he's already
done everything
he did it because he has a profound
sense of duty to this country
he and the american people deserve
better
and don't imagine that biden is going to
stop the lawlessness in our cities by
the way
i'd be using local police as we did when
we were
in office when there were riots in our
federal property at stake
we were able to take care of that we're
able to take care by the use of
not what as wide as this obviously the
use of
local police oh really
here's what obama and biden accomplished
in baltimore
they did nothing except let baltimore
and st
louis ferguson burn and electing biden
is going to make scenes like these play
out in a neighborhood near you
and for those looking to i don't know
for some comfort some moderation some
sanity
biden only offers an assurance to the
far left
and the aoc wing of his party if i'm
electing this passes
i'm gonna be good to go down as almost
progressive presidents in american
history
i'll bet you're also going to be good
you know good to go down as one of the
most manipulated and passive presidents
in american history
my goodness think of bill barr and what
he had to endure today
and then think of biden running the show
oh sorry
whoever his vice president and the old
obama alums
running the show god help us